hello and welcome to a special preview
of the week in 60 minutes which will Air
in full tonight at 6 pm on spectator TV
following the death of yefghani pagosian
I've spoken to The Spectators Russia
correspondent Owen Matthews you can
watch that clip in full here and see the
show tonight at 6 pm on spectator TV
[Music]
hi Ellen thanks for joining spectator TV
you say in your piece for coffee house
at yefghani pregosian was a dead man
walking why was that
well uh for a very simple reason that if
you defy someone as uh who are the track
record of murder and violence like
Vladimir Putin who's uh
um either directly or indirectly killed
so many of his opponents if you actually
come after a man like that in an armed
Insurrection I mean it's pretty clear
that those uh the stakes cannot have
been higher for him uh it's kind of
amazing
um that he survived the the precautions
survived the Mutiny uh it's amazing that
he was allowed to sort of walk the earth
especially the Russian Earth in the two
months intervening uh so in that sense
uh pregosian's death is probably like
the least surprising news story of the
Year from Putin's perspective Owen to
what extent did the Wagner Chief still
represent a threat or was killing
percussion simply an act of Revenge for
the attempted coup several months back
um well I think both
um uh the threat part I think has
actually been more or less neutralized
insofar as that Wagner was partially the
Wagner troops that rebelled under
precautions orders back in June who have
been scattered some of them gone to
Belarus some of them gone to Africa uh
we don't know how many have joined up in
various uh regular Russian army units
like redut which is a Russian army unit
set up especially for former prisoners
uh so I don't think he uh Peter gaussian
was necessarily a military threat but
the fact that he was still at Liberty
was a sort of living proof of Putin's
weakness and uh in that sense the really
important question is you know how much
of his supporters uh are still out there
I mean there's been some chat on Pro
Wagner telegram groups saying you know
we will get revenge we've had a plan you
know for this eventuality you know watch
Kremlin we have no idea how serious
those are I think most people discount
the possibility of a second Wagner
Mutiny uh just Wagner but the bigger
question is uh what about all the
soldiers generals and you know officers
uh security service people bloggers who
supported pragodian and why did they
support precaution they supported
progression because pregosian they
thought was the only guy really fighting
a serious war in Ukraine while all the
rest were being incompetent and stealing
which is probably true
um and um some kind of new head of this
Hydra is kind of going to be dangerous
and threatening to Putin going forward
because if the war doesn't go very well
there's going to be other people who
thought like progression does did and we
can't exclude that they're going to
appear on the political scene at some
point in the future well that was my
next question to you does this death
leave an opening for somebody even more
frightening to come in
uh yes uh it certainly does
um the most dangerous opposition to
Putin is not uh liberals uh and anti-war
voices like Alexander viney the
opposition leader has been spent just
spent two years in jail
um that's not the dangerous opposition
the dangerous opposition
uh are the ultra nationalists and the
Hawks who argue that Putin is sort of
pussy-footing about and not doing enough
to prosecute the Ukraine war and they've
been the most vocal opponents of Putin
on the most vocal critics one of them is
prominent voices of the ultra
nationalists is a guy called
his real name is gibke the former
Defense Minister minister of the
separatist
um danese People's Republic
and he was jailed last month so that's
uh so that guy has been shut down but
there is a large we don't know how large
but definitely vocal
community of nationalists
um in Russia who actually uh have strong
ties and support in the armed forces we
know that
um so they're armed they're angry and
they are opposed to Putin so
um uh the last the last Showdown uh was
obviously the preggers Mutiny it failed
Putin won he survived precautions dead
Putin is not so you know that round goes
to Putin but I think the uh the big
takeaway for anyone
who has plans to challenge Putin from
the previous Mutiny is that
in a progressive Putin's word means
nothing Putin gave his word to Prego
that was the reason why he was in Russia
he just thought
uh thought that it was going to be
business as usual it was definitely not
business as usual
um he seems to be the only person in the
world that kind of considered Putin's
word to be good and Putin broke it so
the real takeaway is if you come with
the Tsar you better finish the job next
time around oh and you mentioned before
that pregosian's still walking around
Russia would have represented a symbol
of sorts for Putin of his own weakness
is that why we saw such a public
assassination Putin's regime has made us
very familiar with the concept of
accidental deaths but this was extremely
public was he trying to make a statement
yeah that's an excellent question I mean
there there is something deliberately
performative about this spectacular act
of violence I mean he wasn't just you
know poisoned he wasn't you know killed
in a car crash pregorson was literally
blown out of the sky so there's you know
clear symbolism to that
um uh part of the symbolism is this was
apparently I mean we don't know quite
yet but I mean there have been witness
reports that suggest there were two
anti-aircraft missiles that down
precautions playing so it's like the
military killed precaution so that's a
symbolism
um he was killed you know violently into
Fireball along with uh many of the
senior members of the Wagner group
notably
formerly the commander and the head of
Wagner group whose cool sign Wagner is
actually because he's an enthusiastic
Nazi uh you may have noticed that
actually
um late Putin Russia seems to share a
casting director with like the Lord of
the Rings because these people are like
incredibly terrifying looking uh Dimitri
woodkin literally looks like the king of
the Orcs And has swastika SS swastika
flashes tattooed on his collarbone as we
know also looks pretty scary
um but the uh all of these people were
traveling together all of the top Wagner
people they were killed in one what
military people call a decapitation
strike but of course it's quite telling
that the most successful decapitation
strikes that the Russian state is
currently carrying out are on its own
side
so what happens to the Wagner group now
Owen that has lost so many of its senior
officials
uh I think it's just going to be taken
over by greedy Uh Russian officers I
mean for many years Wagner has actually
been a kind of uh you know it's like
it's like passing go on a Monopoly board
a lot of top Russian commanders actually
were seconded spent six months in with
Wagner in Africa in Syria made a lot of
money that was how Wagner actually
became so influential among the senior
high command and in fact one of the top
commanders of Wagner was in fact
literally a former deputy defense
minister of the Russian Federation so
there's you know there were a lot of
people who have benefited from this cat
this cash cow now that um because Wagner
has been very busy
you know hoovering up uh you know gold
mines assets gas wells in all the
countries you know from Niger to um uh
Central African Republic to Libya to
Syria uh where it's had operations
um I think our business Empire is just
going to be absorbed by you know
vultures
um in terms of its uh continuing
existence as a threat to Putin um I mean
I don't think it's actually going to be
uh reconstituted in its old form it
can't be
um and that just leaves us sort of a
major Gap in the sort of fighting uh in
the line of battle in Ukraine because uh
pregosian you know if all of his many
uh Legion faults
um was actually indeed one of the most
effective Battlefield commanders uh
around solidar and Bahamut and um one of
the few Russian generals that was
actually able to deliver us
some kind of Victory however
bloody and bloody it was but um that's
now gone no one else so do so you do
think that this assassination will
essentially have a direct effect on
Putin's war against Ukraine
um uh the effect already happened after
the Mutiny and when when Wagner was
essentially sort of dispersed and
officially taken over by the Russian
state so wagon hasn't been in the line
of battle some time not in advance since
the end of May
um uh it's not really the issue of uh
the Wagner fighting forces it's uh the
effect on the Russian war effort I think
is going to be more about you know how
is Putin going to
um uh where is Putin going to get his
Cannon for the fodder from because
Wagner was a really important source of
cannon fodder they recruited as we know
tens of thousands of violent criminals
including murders and murder murderers
and rapists and offered them uh
unconditional discharge after six months
of service
um and uh so you have a cannon for the
problem and you have a who to blame
problem because uh the arguments that
Putin the the precaution made and the
criticism he made of the Russian high
command all those things that he said
have not been addressed not being fixed
that the Army is corrupt it's
inefficient they don't know how to fight
the all of those things are true so if
if the operation still continues to go
wrong or rather if they still you know
continue to lose bits and pieces of
ground to the ukrainians then Putin's
gonna have to come up with a new
narrative you know someone else to play
my last question to you on was something
interesting that stuck out in your piece
where you wrote that progressions
assassination could actually be
interpreted as a sign of weakness from
Vladimir Putin can you elaborate on that
will weakness insofar as
um in the sort of Mafia world mafia-like
world of the inner circle of Putin's
closest Associates what's most important
is personal trust they'll value loyalty
above everything
and part of that loyalty is giving your
word so let's just imagine for a second
this actually is literally a mafia
family you know the the boss has made a
deal with a discontented couple in a
lieutenant who's rebelled and been
forgiven and is you know has his guard
down and then you assassinate him while
his guard is down you've broken your
word what does that do to your
negotiating capabilities in future with
your other couples you know clearly what
you've done is you've just murdered a
man who trusted you so in that sense in
the terms of
um you know that the the what the
Russians called panyatta the
understandings not the laws but the
understandings that govern that sort of
world of the of the high Elite uh Putin
has actually just gone back on his word
and proved himself to be fundamentally
untrustworthy and I think that is
um if not necessarily a sign of weakness
um it's a sign of his um it's going to
weaken him in future I mean the weakness
is really that it fails it proves that
Russia is a failed state that has no
mechanism other than murder to punish
its wrongdoers that's really the sign of
weakness oh and thanks for joining
spectator TV
my great pleasure
[Music]
thank you